>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Ron Charles: This afternoon,
my guest is a celebrated
novelist and poet Ha Jin.
Thank you so much for coming today.
>> Ha Jin: Oh, thank you.
I'm happy to be here again.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
>> Ron Charles: The life of this
remarkable writer began in China
where his father was
a military officer.
At 13, Ha Jin himself joined
the People's Liberation Army
which he stayed with
until he was 19.
He earned a Masters degree
in Literature in China,
and earned a scholarship to Brandeis
University in the late 1980s.
When he and the rest of world
watched the Chinese government
murder democracy demonstrators
in Tiananmen Square in 1989,
he decided to remain
in the United States.
He eventually earned a PhD, and now,
he teaches at Boston University.
Over the years, he's published
several unforgettable novels
about life in China and the
immigrant experience in America.
He's won a number of awards,
including two PEN/Faulkner awards
including for one called "War Trash"
which was also a finalist
for the Pulitzer Prize.
His new novel is called
"The Boat Rocker".
It's a story of a Chinese
patriot named Feng Danlin?
>> Ha Jin: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: Okay.
Who works in New York as a
reporter for a news service
that appeals primarily to
Chinese people living abroad.
And, Danlin is so passionate
about exposing what he calls
"the towering corruption of Chinese
politics" with his acid tongue
and his heart stabbing commentary.
His personal credo is
"Honesty is strength.
Democracy dies in darkness."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Now, you must have started "The
Boat Rocker" several years ago.
>> Ha Jin: Many years ago.
>> Ron Charles: And, yet, it's
being published at a time,
at a climate of ferocious
attacks on the press.
How is that possible?
>> Ha Jin: I don't know.
Maybe something, you know,
really, it's beyond myself.
Always, there is some coincidence.
The same thing happened with "War
Trash", and the abuse of prisoners.
By the way, I started the
book there was no such thing
in my, on my horizon, and.
But, this book, in fact, I started
my, started on the, in 2007.
>> Ron Charles: What
inspired you to write a story
about a Chinese journalist
in America who's so excited
about freedom of expression?
>> Ha Jin: Back in 2003,
there was a friend of mine
who was a freelancer,
freelancing journalist.
He wrote a series of exposes
about a novel of a similar kind.
Not exact the same by
Canadian immigrant.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Ha Jin: And, because this,
my friend's political
position, he was very radical.
>> Ron Charles: Radical
in what sense?
>> Ha Jin: He supported
Taiwan's independence.
>> Ron Charles: Okay.
>> Ha Jin: And, debated.
>> Ron Charles: All right.
>> Ha Jin: Independence.
So, he was viewed as
a kind of enemy.
More than a distant enemy of China.
>> Ron Charles: Of
the [inaudible] state.
>> Ha Jin: Yes.
So, [inaudible] expose
didn't get anywhere.
He was completely suppressed.
Couldn't get anywhere.
>> Ron Charles: What
about in America?
>> Ha Jin: Even in America
didn't get anywhere.
Very briefly people, you know,
it was published online,
but didn't get anywhere.
>> Ron Charles: I know the feeling.
>> Ha Jin: So, was amazed.
I was really amazed by, you know,
the power that we could manage
to suppress the voice like that.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
President Trump has called American
journalists really dishonest people,
bad people, sick people, people who
don't like America, and he's mused
about how much he'd like to
arrest and jail journalists.
How does that kind of
language strike you?
How does it make you
feel, as someone who's?
>> Ha Jin: Sure.
But, I think, again, that is
against the Constitution, right?
And, I think apparently, that was
really, that was not American.
I think that kind of
stuff is not American.
We, it's more like something
from the Chinese government.
[laughs]
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
[ Applause ]
Danlin, this journalist who's
the center of your novel thinks
that rocking the boat is not
just right, it's a sacred duty.
>> Ha Jin: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: Do
you feel that way?
>> Ha Jin: For me,
it's not just duty.
It's a way, how I exist, I think.
That is very important.
All I have is a voice.
As long as I continue to write,
I have a voice of my own.
I think that's important.
>> Ron Charles: Are you, does your
work get any attention in China?
Are you allowed to
travel there, speak there?
>> Ha Jin: I couldn't.
You know, I've been in the states
for 32, I couldn't go back.
And, even my parents died,
when they were dying,
still I couldn't go
back to see them.
And, so I really, personally,
I cannot go back to China
or have anything to do in China.
But, about a third of my
books got published in China.
>> Ron Charles: Really?
>> Ha Jin: But, many of
them, really, censored.
And, for instance, I
have a book I say, like,
of poems that just came out.
But, all the poems have
political resonance were pulled.
So, I felt all the
teeth were pulled.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Ha Jin: From that book.
>> Ron Charles: And, this book,
has it been published in China?
>> Ha Jin: No, no.
It's impossible.
This is.
>> Ron Charles: Impossible, you say.
>> Ha Jin: Impossible.
Impossible.
Only a third of my books.
For instance, for a short story
collection like "The Bridegroom",
they publish it, but when they came
to me, I saw two stories missing.
>> Ron Charles: Oh.
>> Ha Jin: Two stories
missing, so basically,
they were somehow,
they were incomplete.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
Yes. Well, Danlin's passion
for American journalism
sometimes sounds kind of naïve.
>> Ha Jin: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: He tells one critic,
"In this great country, America,
people go by the rules, and
reporters always publish the truth."
>> Ha Jin: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: And, I
know a lot of journalists.
I am a journalist, and I
think that is generally true.
And, yet, when he says it like
that, it kind of makes me cringe.
Is he being set, are you setting
him up as some kind of a zealot?
Is this a parody of?
>> Ha Jin: You know,
he's a troubled man.
So, psychologically, he's, you
know, he has a lot of problem, too.
A lot of problems.
He, the moment he arrived, his
wife gave him divorce papers,
and his Chinese passport
was confiscated.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Ha Jin: And, he, basically,
he was forced into exile.
So, he was troubled.
So, there was kind of
a kind of entangled,
conjugated feelings
between him and China.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Ha Jin: So, he's
trying to find this kind
of a different value
system to sustain himself.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Ha Jin: So, he, that's why he had
to believe in democracy and freedom,
and of course, eventually, he knows.
>> Ron Charles: Knows what?
>> Ha Jin: Knows, you know, it
doesn't always work that way.
He finds American, you know,
official appear basically
in response to Chinese
government's request.
And, basically, they also cooperated
with the Chinese government
indirectly.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
Your point, your theme of the
book is that American freedom
of expression is more complex,
more compromised than we let on.
>> Ha Jin: I think so.
But, yes, there's all, there are
always some kind of the seedy side.
I think I, on the one
hand, American, you know,
I like the American idealism.
You know, we're supposed to be the
city [inaudible] city on the hill.
That's great.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Ha Jin: The vision, the
beacon of freedom and democracy.
On the other hand,
American pragmatism.
That's also part of
the American character.
We calculate everything
by dollars, and.
>> Ron Charles: Danlin has to
learn that having free expression
and having the money to express
oneself are two different things.
>> Ha Jin: Two different things.
Yes. Eventually, he learn that
because even the agency was.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Ha Jin: Bothered by
the Chinese government.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
You can express yourself freely,
but if no one's listening,
it's a tree falling in the forest.
Can you describe for us, to people
who don't know much about China,
haven't been there, what are
the essentially differences
between the media in this
country and in China?
>> Ha Jin: In China,
I think, basically,
there is no freedom of the media.
Basically, really, there is,
for instance, something happened
in [inaudible] at the central
government they will issue a text
basically to all the
agencies, all the newspapers
and TV stations will
follow the same format.
So, you cannot go beyond that.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Ha Jin: And, but in this
country, basically, every agency,
every paper has his own
room to report a truth.
I think. That's a huge difference.
For instance, recently, there was a
counter border dispute between China
and India, and the China
side, basically, backed down.
But, they reported as a huge
victory in their troops retreat,
retreated from the occupied ground.
But, the truth is, the
Chinese government agreed
to stop building the road.
That was a huge, huge setback to
the Chinese government's plan.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Ha Jin: But, this was
unknown to the Chinese.
Not reported at all.
>> Ron Charles: So, there are many
newspapers, many news sources,
but they're all basically
telling the same story.
>> Ha Jin: Exactly the same.
The propaganda department.
They issue the order.
You can't go beyond that.
>> Ron Charles: In this country,
we hear so much, so many references
to "the media" as though
it were some sort
of monolithic thing,
but of course, it's not.
>> Ha Jin: No.
It's not. That's why there're
varied voices and diverse voices
that make people, you know, we
have a different perspectives,
our own personal take on events.
But, in China, most of the
people, just the one voice.
That's very, make people
blind to realities.
>> Ron Charles: We're
still trying to figure
out to what extent the Russians
influenced public opinion
on our election.
Do you see the Chinese government
influencing public opinion
or reporting in this country?
>> Ha Jin: Yes.
Yes. And.
>> Ron Charles: How.
>> Ha Jin: For instance, there are
some news agencies basically they
give the feeling that
they are just the branch
of the Chinese government
official, official media.
For instance, there's one
called Doorway, it's similar,
similar like People's [inaudible]
overseas [inaudible] edition.
And, also, I think even
American Chinese language media
or newspapers, they have
to beware of the responses
from the Chinese government.
So, that is also indirect
censorship.
Lot of things they can't
just report blindly, openly.
>> Ron Charles: Do you
think we're naïve
about how foreign governments are
influencing our public opinion?
>> Ha Jin: I think to
some standard, yes.
I do believe the Russians
and the Chinese, they try.
They try hard, and
not just directly.
For instance, Trump has
family businesses in China,
and so there are ways for the
Chinese government, basically,
to influence officials
holding the offices.
That's normal.
Even from, you know, early,
the Bush Administration.
I remember clearly the Chinese,
once there was a dispute
within China the United States.
A Chinese delegation landed
in Washington D.C. airport.
They said, "We're not
talking to the Bush Jr.,
President Bush Jr. We're
going to his father
and asking the father
to teach him lesson."
So.
[ Laughter ]
>> Ron Charles: Wow.
>> Ha Jin: So, really, they
have, we are, they have ways of.
They, my feeling is that they
speak different language.
They communicate on
different frequencies
that we don't know about those.
>> Ron Charles: The plot
of your novel which is,
it's kind of remarkable, is that
Danlin receives an assignment
to expose the truth about
a romance novel from China.
>> Ha Jin: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: It's
about, it's about 911.
>> Ha Jin: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: It sounds like a
kind of "Fifty Shades of 9/11".
[ Laughter ]
And, for some reason, the Chinese
government takes an interest
in promoting this romance novel,
and the Bush people also promote it.
>> Ha Jin: That was [inaudible].
>> Ron Charles: There's a lot
of different people
promoting this novel.
>> Ha Jin: Yes.
Yes.
>> Ron Charles: But, it's just a
novel, but Danlin becomes obsessed
with exposing it as
a work of propaganda.
There are lucrative
Hollywood contracts,
etc. Why would the Communist Party
take an interest in a romance novel?
>> Ha Jin: See [inaudible]
government is involved.
Very often, it's just one or two
officials who have the connections
with the author or the publisher.
So, either [inaudible] use public,
you know, the power of their office
to sponsor [inaudible] like that.
In the actually [inaudible]
more serious than that.
In fact, it was reported
the novel was accepted by,
was purchased by James Cameron,
you know, the great Director.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Ha Jin: Comedian Directors.
You know, for millions of dollars.
It's really, it's even more absurd.
>> Ron Charles: Than your book.
>> Ha Jin: Than my book.
>> Ron Charles: And, now Danlin, it
comes out later, I guess early on,
that this novel is
written by his ex-wife.
So, he's being asked to expose as
propaganda a novel by his ex-wife.
That's the kind of assignment
that would never be made
in a legitimate U.S. newspaper.
>> Ha Jin: I know.
Personal, yes.
Conflict of interest.
>> Ron Charles: Yes, that would
be a clear conflict of interest,
and any newspaper I know of.
Why did you pursue
that sort of a plot?
>> Ha Jin: Because I think I
want him, he's not just flat.
You know, black and white character.
There's a personal
motivation involved.
I do believe personal
motivations at historical moment.
That is where often
change a lot of things.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
Yes. And, he, of course, is
convinced that he can do this
without any influence at all.
He will be completely objective as
he goes about exposing his ex-wife.
She's, he's totally convinced
himself that he will be.
>> Ha Jin: I know.
Yes.
>> Ron Charles: But, that
does seem absurd to me.
Which raises the issue.
We're laughing, and it is funny.
I think you're a brilliant novelist,
but I do not think
you're a funny novelist.
[ Laughter ]
But, this book is really funny.
I mean, it totally took me off guard
that you were writing
this witty, funny story.
What did it feel different to you
to be writing what is often comedy?
>> Ha Jin: I only, you
know, before this book, or,
there's a small novel called
"In the Pond", my earlier book.
>> Ron Charles: Okay.
>> Ha Jin: So, this book, in terms
of style, they are, you know, comic.
>> Ron Charles: Okay.
>> Ha Jin: But, in the, really, I
agree, you know, people, you know,
my publisher didn't know
how to deal with this.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
Yeah.
>> Ha Jin: Basically,
this was not typical.
>> Ron Charles: No, it's not.
>> Ha Jin: My book at
all, and but I really
about to write a kind
of cynical dark humor.
That kind of novel.
>> Ron Charles: Does it have
any precedent in your life?
Have you been writing comedy
and not showing anybody?
>> Ha Jin: No, just before this,
there's only one "In the Pond".
>> Ron Charles: Oh, "The Pond".
>> Ha Jin: "In the Pond", yeah.
"In the Pond", but that book,
even, there was not, there was no,
there was published by a very
small place called Zoland Books
in Cambridge in Massachusetts.
>> Ron Charles: Oh.
I know Zoland.
They're gone now.
>> Ha Jin: Yeah.
It went out of business.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Ha Jin: Twenty years ago.
>> Ha Jin: So, the book, basically,
it, most people might not know it.
>> Ron Charles: I didn't
know about it.
>> Ha Jin: Yeah, it's, but it is
the same in terms of the style.
They're similar.
>> Ron Charles: How funny.
>> Ha Jin: But, this one
is, the [inaudible] is told
in the first person, so
that is the difference.
>> Ron Charles: And, it has a
kind of Kafkaesque comedy to it.
The increasingly absurd,
bizarre situations.
>> Ha Jin: Yeah, I do believe
reality is more bizarre
than fiction.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Ha Jin: But, I really
believe in that.
>> Ron Charles: I was talking to
Jasmine Moore, and she said she had
to write a particular
story as nonfiction
because if she wrote it is
fiction, no one would believe her.
>> Ha Jin: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Ha Jin: [inaudible] very
often, [inaudible] you shave them.
You want to make them fictionalized,
make them [inaudible]
the story better.
People don't believe in that.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> Ha Jin: But, reality,
you will reality,
they are even darker, more bizarre.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
Yeah. Like Joseph Conrad, you're
writing in an adapted language,
and when you accepted the National
Book award for "Waiting", you said,
"I also wish to thank America, a
land of generosity and abundance,
but they have accepted
me as a citizen.
Above all, I thank the English
language which is embracive
and vibrant and has
provided me with a niche
where I can do meaningful work."
Can you explain to us
what it's like to try
and create art in another language?
>> Ha Jin: Oh, there was a
lot of, lot of frustration.
I think in the beginning,
uncertainty was a big
[inaudible] part
because I didn't know whether I
could write and how far I could go.
But, the beauty of the language,
the English language is that it has
within it a grand tradition in which
non-native speaking authors became
essential writers such
as Conrad and Nabokov.
So, in other words, the
road is there already open.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Ha Jin: So, really,
there's nothing original.
It all depended on when I have the
courage, the luck, and the ability.
So, [inaudible] in
fact, uncertainty.
Certainty is another
human condition.
So, we had to take [inaudible],
and that's part of the process.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Ha Jin: That's also
price for freedom, right?
And, we are responsible for
ourself, ourselves, body and soul.
So, that.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Ha Jin: In that sense,
I could take uncertainty
as a [inaudible] process.
Eventually, I realized,
in fact, this is good.
Because if everything
is clear and certain.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Ha Jin: I cannot be a bad book.
>> Ron Charles: Yes,
I know what you mean.
Yes. No, it has to be.
There has to be tension in there.
>> Ha Jin: Mediocre, mediocre book.
Yes, you need a nervousness,
the edge.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
But, what do mean about English
being embracive language.
Not just that it embraces
other words.
I suppose you means something else.
>> Ha Jin: Yes.
But, I look at, you
know, the people writing,
lot of people from
different languages.
And, the but things you can't
accept, all the language,
all kinds of English is
as a literary language.
That's a great, great,
you know, phenomenon.
I really, for other authors.
For people from different
backgrounds, different languages,
this is a great, great opportunity.
Great, great space.
I think a great space
where you can work.
For instance, Chinese is a
highly literary language.
People speak all kinds of dialects.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Ha Jin: And, when
we come to the page,
you have to write a language that's
separated from natural speech.
>> Ron Charles: Oh.
>> Ha Jin: It's a literary language.
So, in other words, that language
is somehow already formal.
>> Ron Charles: It shapes the story.
>> Ha Jin: It shapes, yes.
The dialect, many dialects
are not presented
in the literary language, discourse.
>> Ron Charles: There's
no way to represent them?
>> Ha Jin: No, no.
But, by contrast, the English,
all kind of [inaudible].
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Ha Jin: You write well.
Everything can be accepted
as a literary language.
>> Ron Charles: Google
Translate gives us the impression
that translation is a
matter of replacing one word
with a word in another language.
>> Ha Jin: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: But,
that's not the case.
>> Ha Jin: No.
No, no, no.
It's no, no.
It's completely different because
when you write the literary work,
you have, that's always playfulness.
You want the language to be
somehow slightly odd, fresh.
Where, academic language
deformalization, right?
You make unfamiliar to others.
But, in fact, for people
from another,
people from different languages,
[inaudible] task is what
can I bring to English.
So, that's for me because
I started as a poet,
and that was a question
on my mind constantly.
>> Ron Charles: Without
embarrassing you,
what do you think you
bring to the language?
>> Ha Jin: I, basically, I try
to really try to write languages
that have different
resonances, that sound foreign,
but at the same time,
entirely natural.
That's my vision.
>> Ron Charles: No, I think
that's a vision you realize.
>> Ha Jin: I don't know.
I don't know.
>> Ron Charles: You do.
You do.
>> Ha Jin: Oh, thank you.
By that, you know, I try to
imagine because other people
from my situation, I didn't,
I had not met a single person
who spoke English before I was 21.
>> Ron Charles: Job.
>> Ha Jin: So, and there
was no way for me to,
to just write standard English.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Ha Jin: Because
that would be flat.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Ha Jin: Unoriginal anyway.
>> Ha Jin: So, it's better
for me to basically just
to write make it strange,
a little bit strange.
>> Ron Charles: Do you
conceive of stories
in Chinese or in English now?
>> Ha Jin: I always in English.
>> Ron Charles: In English.
>> Ha Jin: In English, yeah.
>> Ron Charles: If you conceived
of this story in Chinese,
it would be a different story?
>> Ha Jin: Very different.
As I said just now,
there's a language,
the language Chinese
literary language,
it has little to do
with natural speech.
It's created by all the Chinese
to share no matter
what dialect you speak.
That's different, very different.
So, but the English is
really, it's remarkable,
just so close to natural speech.
In that sense, it is very embracive.
Everything can be included.
>> Ron Charles: Including
Danlin's thoughts.
>> Ha Jin: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: His urgency,
his naivete, all those things
that you capture in both his
thoughts and his spoken language.
When he sounds so strident that
it almost sounds like a parody
of somebody believing in America.
>> Ha Jin: Yes.
But, see, that's the situation I
should be more elaborate about this.
That is, when the character's
the one that's communicating,
especially this Chinese [inaudible].
I would hear Chinese expressions.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Ha Jin: So, I would adapt.
Try to not transcribe,
but adapt, adjust.
Make them more comprehensible
to the English ear.
So, I do, the Chinese,
the language is behind,
in the background for the creation.
>> Ron Charles: Because
these characters.
>> Ha Jin: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: Also speak Chinese.
>> Ha Jin: Yes, yes.
Exactly. So, I wouldn't say this
has nothing to do with Chinese.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Ha Jin: Chinese
always in the background.
It make noise.
>> Ron Charles: Yes,
and it influences the
way they speak English.
>> Ha Jin: Yes.
Yes. Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: I thought it
was a fascinating novel in terms
of its themes about journalism and
the place of journalism in America.
Oh, it's really troubling.
>> Ha Jin: Thank you.
Yes.
>> Ron Charles: Made me
think in more complex ways
about the privileges we have and
how they are so routinely abused.
>> Ha Jin: Yes, a lot of things
that, you know, I didn't expect,
but when it was published, a lot
of things became transparent.
For instance, the [inaudible]
in the early 2000s, I think,
they began to acquire
media facilities.
I was troubled by it.
I talked to some friends.
They didn't care, but
it gradually got bigger.
Now, they're just newspapers
and TV stations,
but [inaudible] there are
a lot of other things.
Even companies at Hollywood.
>> Ron Charles: Yes, what your
novel explores and brings out is
that what we think of
as government control
of the media is far too simplistic.
It's not just the governments
will censor stories.
>> Ha Jin: No.
>> Ron Charles: It's that
they will obscure the truth.
>> Ha Jin: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: By
flooding our lives
with so many slightly
different stories.
>> Ha Jin: Yes.
That's the, I think that
comes propaganda, they don't,
they don't report anything
without some kind of facts.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Ha Jin: [laughs] Under it.
Usually, they shave the
facts, they start the facts,
but often there is some truth in it,
but they stretch it and distort it,
make it feel differently.
>> Ron Charles: And, promoting
so many different stories
that after a while, you
just kind of check out.
Cool, what can we believe.
>> Ha Jin: I know.
Yes.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Ha Jin: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: Would you, it's such
an important subject for this town.
I'm just so grateful
you wrote this book.
>> Ha Jin: Oh, thank you.
>> Ron Charles: Would you take
some questions from the audience?
>> Ha Jin: Sure.
I'll be, yeah.
I'll be very happy.
>> Ron Charles: There's two
microphones, one here, and one here.
Please come to the mic.
Wave your hands a bit.
It's hard for us to see you,
the lights are so bright.
Yes, sir.
>> Thanks very much.
It's very interesting
to hear your remarks.
My question is about
"Nanjing Requiem".
For those who don't
know, I urge them to buy
and read the story of
the Nanjing massacre.
I read in the New York Times review
of that, that Jinling University
at that heart of that was
a symbol of civilization.
And, when I read the novel, I
didn't see it in an allegorical way.
I just thought it was a very
compelling story, and I wondered
as you were writing it whether
you were thinking allegorically
or whether you were just telling the
events as they unfolding in Nanjing.
>> Ha Jin: Hi.
Thank you.
It's kind.
The book is really, it's very hard
because there were so many authors
who tried, not only Chinese, in
fact, authors in [inaudible] tried
to really write about that
horrendous historical event.
For me, I think I made
it allegorical,
but it's not, it was not my purpose.
There was a, there was a narrative
about missionaries in China.
Always, these people were described
as kind of semi spies and people
who really were [inaudible].
To some extent, that was
true, but on the other hand,
there's another kind of
story that was not reported.
The Chinese didn't know that it
also did a lot of good things.
For instance, in China, every
hospital would have a red cross.
That is from the Catholic church.
People would know where to
look for medical service.
In this country, we don't have that,
but in China, it's always there.
Always there.
That's, you know, that's
a good influence.
Good missionary work.
And, in a same, in a same situation,
I want to really write about the,
basically, the group of American
missionaries how they were involved
in this tragedy.
I think that it was an
important moment in history,
and because this is [inaudible]
can not only, you know,
because some event happened
between China and Japan,
it involved people
from other countries.
It was an international event.
Toward the end of the book,
it was, it became transparent
that the Chinese didn't
collect any material evidence.
Only Americans shot, Americans
and Germans shot photographs,
even footage of the atrocities.
But, for me, personally,
basically, it was a huge challenge.
I really, I made so many
missteps in the beginning.
I told everything in third
person, but after 30, 32 drafts,
I couldn't continue anymore.
I had to scratch the whole,
scrap the whole thing and restart
and equate a character who is
narrator as assistant to Minnie.
And, but for me, that,
personally, as an artist,
that book was important because
afterward, I felt I could write.
And, any novel, no matter
how difficult, I could,
I could try to manage
to confront it.
So, before that, I didn't
have that kind of confidence.
So, for me, it's very personal.
It's like a hurdle.
I had to cross it.
>> I'm sorry.
Two of my favorite books of yours
are "The Crazed" and "A Free Life".
And, to some degree, characters
seem to be defined by the degree
to which they resist change
or adaptation or degree
to which they embrace or adapt
to change in their lives.
But, there seems to be sort of
a sadness of those characters
who adapt in terms of
dreams that die or.
>> Ha Jin: Yes.
>> Or, things they leave behind
that they can never take with them.
I would like to ask you, you know,
do you see something
redemptive in that adaptation?
You know, is there, do
they become more focused,
and how does that relate
to your own experience?
>> Ha Jin: I'm glad.
Thank you so much.
Those books are very close
to my heart, and in fact,
"The Crazed" was my first novel,
but I didn't have the
skill to finish it.
So, it came out after I had
published two, six books.
And, I think there is a redemptive
kind of aspect of their experience.
I think, toward the end, they
all become, somehow, they become,
the characters become independent.
They want to go their own way
whether they perish or survive,
but they want the freedom
to seek their own existence.
In that way, my personal
experience does correspond to that.
>> Thank you.
I do have a question that may
challenge your earlier comment
about the modern Chinese language.
You said it was, it is
standardized and some kind of stiff.
But, I know this is somehow
true in public realm.
>> Ha Jin: Yes.
>> For example, Chinese media.
>> When they are writing, it's
really some standard language.
But, from my own knowledge of
Chinese literature in Chinese
in the past three decades.
I see some really good
examples of dialect writing.
>> Ha Jin: Yeah.
>> For example, [inaudible] and
newer experiments by a novelist
from Shanghai [inaudible].
I just want to ask if you're
informed of this development,
and if yes, how would
you make sense of it?
Thank you.
>> Ha Jin: Okay.
That's a good question.
I know these writings,
especially [inaudible].
I think that that's an
experimental novel trying
to incorporate [inaudible]
dialect into the stand Mandarin.
And, but, again, it's not
a pure dialect because,
but people can feel
this is different.
That is a great experiment.
I think that's why on
different occasion,
I said it's a political gesture
because the book challenges
the political linguistic order.
And, as for [inaudible], there's
another, you know, a great novelist
who by the last year
or two years ago.
I think his book is
not based, I mean,
the language is not exactly based
on the dialect, original dialect.
I heard him speak, and [inaudible].
The way they speak the language,
it's very hard to understand,
to be understood by me even.
But, the, on page,
absolutely transparent.
The style's very clear, and I
think in Chinese literature,
there has always been
a kind of a tradition.
People from the south
suffer from the fact
that their dialects
are not presented
in the official standard
of Mandarin.
Whereas, the people from the
north, they have that advantage.
That's why a lot of
people from Beijing
and from the north very often
they write more naturally
because the official language is
close to their natural speech.
So, there is a huge difference.
This, I think, is in fact,
reflect where historical facts.
See, the Chinese, when the first
emperor, when he came to power,
he basically violently,
he killed all the scripts.
At the time, there were all kind
of [inaudible] script, bird script.
All kinds, but he killed them all.
So, there's only one written word,
so [inaudible] in Chinese history,
political history,
the cultural history,
there is a term called
rectification of word, the word.
That means the word must be precise,
and that is part of
the ruling machine.
You cannot violate,
change the shape of words.
So, I think that is, that is, but
the two books you mentioned, really,
I think they, especially
[inaudible],
I think is a great experiment.
I think more authors should do that.
In other words, people began to
try to make the dialect present
in the literary discourse.
But, this is just the beginning.
>> Ron Charles: When you say the
word can't be shaped or changed,
do you mean its physical
representation on the page,
or do you mean something
about its meaning?
>> Ha Jin: Both.
Especially the, even the
physical presentation.
>> Ron Charles: And, how does
that effect you as a poet
where the shades of meaning
and the shaping of words seems
to be the whole industry of poetry?
>> Ha Jin: I know.
That's why, that's why
the literary discourse has
to be, has been some official.
It might be less now, but
conventionally, it was important,
especially when you write a report
to the palace, to the court.
I think there was one
case the guy drop a dot.
He thought he would be beheaded.
He was terrified.
There are moments like that.
You're not supposed to
change the shape of the word.
>> Ron Charles: Do you run up
against though, you don't write in,
you don't write poetry
in Chinese, I suppose.
>> Ha Jin: I do.
I do, in fact, in recent
years, my wife was sick.
So, for a long time, I couldn't
get into a start a novel.
So, I began to write poetry.
Originally, I thought I
wrote them in Chinese,
but I thought they would
be just the drafts.
So, [inaudible] good poetry English.
But, once I started, I felt
in Chinese it was still my first
language, my mother tongue.
So, these should be poems in
Chinese, so I began to publish
and publish a lot, in
fact, late in recent years.
I published two books of
poetry in Chinese, but then,
I rewrote them, some of them.
>> Ron Charles: In English.
>> Ha Jin: In English.
>> Ron Charles: Did you
do your own translations?
>> Ha Jin: Not translation.
I just rewrote them.
>> Ron Charles: What do you mean?
Why is that different to you?
>> Ha Jin: Lot of poems,
a lot of poems,
you can't just translate them.
For instance, I'll give
you two lines, and you go.
In Chinese, it would be
something like [speaking Chinese].
This is like, "I landed in the
place my ancestors never heard of.
I need to develop another
kind of fortitude."
But, this, the last line is not
that good because that is flat.
>> Ron Charles: The fortitude.
>> Ha Jin: But, in
Chinese, it's very neat
because there is a rhyme there.
But, in English, I
rewrote the last line.
I said, "I need to
grow a new backbone."
A new image.
So, this is the case, I have
to rewrite them, not
just translate them.
>> Ron Charles: That's fascinating.
>> Ha Jin: So, I rewrote some
of the poems so there was a book
of poems forthcoming
from Copper Canyon Press.
So, I was, it's a convoluted
process,
but I'm very fortunate somehow.
I manage it, to get them published.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
That's fascinating.
Yes, sir.
>> No, I think you kind
of answered my question.
A few years ago, you translate
one of your work "A Good Fall".
>> Ha Jin: Yes.
>> Into Chinese by yourself.
I just want to ask how does it feel.
I mean, after all these decades
writing English, how did it feel
for you to write in Chinese again?
You have any plans to write an
original novel in Chinese again,
and what makes you to
translate that book
into Chinese in the first place?
>> Ha Jin: Okay.
Let me answer your
question backward.
When I, in a, you have a collection
of short stories to be translated,
you should keep the stories
copyrights, the translation rights
in your own hands because
it'll be too complicated
if another person translated
your stories.
Because every time a magazine or
anthology want to reprint a piece,
you have to go to the translator.
So, for practical reasons,
it's always better
to do the short fiction by yourself.
Now, also, short stories,
there were less words.
So, that doesn't pay much,
so it's better for you to be,
to do the work more careful, you
know, more laborious the process.
But, as for the writing,
I felt, you know, really,
I enjoy that, the writing process.
Suddenly, I felt I was so
at home with the language.
But, to be honest, I didn't
spend enough time, perhaps.
Maybe I spent 5% of the labor
of the [inaudible] compared
with the English, the English text.
But, I, there was [inaudible]
of loss.
I do believe that if
I wrote in Chinese,
I would become different
kind of a writer.
Perhaps more like a poet, but
I think this one, even poetry,
I didn't invest enough energy in my
personal existence in the language.
So, I couldn't say much about that.
But, at least my recent two books
of poetry in Chinese does show
that I really, I could have become
a meaningful writer in Chinese.
But, again, we have to accept
what the world has made of us.
[laughs]
>> Ron Charles: Fascinating concept.
Yes.
>> Hi. So, in my last
year of college,
I took a class called The
American Novel with Philip Fisher,
and the last book that we read in
the class, kind of the culmination
of the class was your book
"Waiting" which was striking
because it wasn't even
set in America.
The other non-English speaking or.
>> Ha Jin: Sure.
>> Original English native
author that we read was Nabokov.
And, I guess, I had my own kind of
reactions and hypotheses in thinking
about why this book
fit in this class.
I was reminded of when my
father told me many years ago
that he believes that China will
eventually become a democracy
and led me to wonder about how many
generations of people and authors
that have to wait until
that is ever realized.
I wonder, maybe, if it was because
of, kind of the universality
of waiting as the kind
of a state of being.
But, I wondered, I guess you're
the most natural person to ask
and to hypothesize about why
"Waiting" is really
an American novel.
>> Ha Jin: And, I knew,
Fisher was my teacher, too.
But, at the time, he
was at Brandeis,
but then he went to Harvard.
And, I heard that the book was
taught as American, American novel.
In fact, there were many courses.
In fact, a colleague of
mine also have their novel
in his American fiction class.
I think the universality
is a big part of it.
Also, the language is a combination
of American idiom,
the American idiom.
Also, some Chinese
accent in that novel.
I think, also, the
perception of the world.
That's important.
Without my American existence,
the [inaudible] experience,
I couldn't have possibly
written a book like that.
So, the other was the creation.
It's also part of American
experience.
But, also, it was published
in America.
That's important.
>> Ron Charles: That's
why it's an American book.
>> Ha Jin: Yeah, and
nobody, in fact.
In the beginning, people
say, "This book,
no [inaudible] publisher
will take such a book."
They thought it was too plain, and
the language was basically the book,
the experiences are so common.
But, I, in other words, entered the
sensibilities America in many ways.
I knew what was essential to
human experience, so I didn't go
to any flashy novel experience.
But, I tried to stay with facts.
In other words, my American
experience sharpened my eyes
for the meaningful details.
So, there are many ways
to justify the choice
of [inaudible] as an American novel.
But, also, eventually, I have
become an American author, I think.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
We think so.
>> Thank you.
>> Ha Jin: Thank you.
>> Ron Charles: Yes, ma'am.
>> I'm just curious about your sort
of foundational American experience
which were those first years at,
in university as a
young man at Brandeis.
What, how did that appear to you,
and what did you take advantage
of in those first few years when
you were making your decisions
about becoming part
of our American life?
>> Ha Jin: You know, when I
came, I, as, to do graduate work,
I had a wonderful job waiting
for me in China, in a university
as a researcher or translator,
and also professor for
American Literature.
But, so, I didn't plan to immigrate.
I work very hard, but I was
separated from my family
because my wife and son were
not allowed to come with me.
So, it was painful.
We were, in that sense.
I had to work very hard to make
enough money for, so the bank.
In order to get the Visa, you
have to have, like, $3000,
you know, saving account.
And, so I really work, but I
did all kinds of work, jobs.
I think that helped me a lot.
Custodian and nighttime
watchman and bus boy.
I did all kinds of work.
I think that's very important.
I started from scratch,
making me feel that, you know,
how as a person you bring
bread to table, how that,
the process, how that works.
That's important for me.
So, that is really
down to earth process.
I think what is most important
moment in my, in my first year,
in fact, I, people knew, my
fellow graduate students all knew
that I was married, but
I had no family with me.
So, my one Indian student,
Sangeeta, who lived a floor
under my apartment, below
my apartment, at a party,
she ask me why did you, why
didn't you bring your family
with me, with you.
I said government doesn't allow,
and he said, "Why don't you?"
She said, "Why don't you
sue your government?"
[ Laughter ]
For her part, it was careless and
[inaudible] question I didn't know.
I didn't know how to put my
head around the question.
But, it stayed all the
time, for many, many years.
Because essentially, that is,
in fact, the question pointing
to the heart of a democracy
which is, in theory,
in the eyes of the law, the
Constitution, the individual,
and the country are equal.
For, also, in this country, we
do have that kind of legal system
to guarantee the individual,
civil rights, at least in theory.
So, individual can sue a
government, but in China,
China's Constitution is fabulous.
But, it's just piece of paper.
Nobody take it seriously.
You can't sue your government,
so I think that was very,
very important moment, really
shaped my understanding
and perception of American society.
Eventually, in fact, at the
beginning of this year, [inaudible],
he overturned President Trump's ban
on the seven Muslim
majority countries
from coming to the United States.
Right? Just a regular
judge overturned
that because it doesn't
compart with our Constitution.
So, in other words, a simple
question that really resonate stay
with me, like basically if
the manifest points to many,
many meaningful aspects for
American life and culture.
>> Ron Charles: It's just such
a pleasure to talk to you.
>> Ha Jin: Thank you.
>> Ron Charles: I'm so
glad you were here today.
>> Ha Jin: Thank you.
>> Ron Charles: Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.